MALE SPEAKER: Hi.
We're back here at Devoxx.
And I'm here with Sam.
Welcome, Sam.
SAM DUTTON: Hey.
Good to see you.
MALE SPEAKER: And we're
here to talk about media.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: In the large
grand scheme of things, media.
Maybe before we talk about
WebRTC, which is obviously
the topic we'll get into,
let's talk about media
and what it represents
in the web today.
Do you want to say
a few words about--
SAM DUTTON: Absolutely.
MALE SPEAKER: How media is
being consumed, produced.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah,
it's astonishing.
Yeah.
So I guess what we've seen on
the web is kind of two trends.
The first is sort of obvious.
We have all these devices
that we're using now.
More mobile phones than
pencils or toothbrushes,
all that stuff.
But with that has come, it's
not the same old, same old.
There's a change in what
we're doing on the web.
And these devices which
are kind of oriented
to consumption and
communication in some ways,
have led to a change in
what we're doing on the web.
And with that, we're
getting the rise and rise
of media on the web.
The figures I had
recently from Cisco
saying within the
next three years
or so, we'll have something like
potentially 90% of web traffic
will be video.
That's TV, On Demand,
communication, and so on.
But that's a huge shift in what
people are doing on the web.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
And that means we need
to evolve the standards.
And as part of that, the
WebRTC plays a big-- I mean,
that's what comes to mind.
So tell us about
maybe what WebRTC is.
Let's start there.
And for those that
have not used it
or that don't really
know what it is.
SAM DUTTON: OK.
So WebRTC is a way to do
real-time communication
in the browser on the web.
And it's really well supported
now on Chrome, and desktop
for Android, Firefox, and
desktop, and Android and so on.
And what it means is that
plug-in-free, royalty-free,
open-source software, you
can build that into your web
apps to do the
obvious use cases,
stuff like video chat
right in your web app.
You can run a telephone
system in your web apps.
You can put a
telephone in a web app,
just with a few
lines of JavaScript.
MALE SPEAKER: So we're
talking about replacing
existing, potentially
expensive software that's
been running this
type of use cases
for the longest time with free,
open-source, open standards.
SAM DUTTON: And
the cool thing is
that WebRTC is designed
to work peer-to-peer.
So the existing
frameworks, we've
always involved a kind
of centralized model
where you're running
someone else's services,
but essentially
the core of WebRTC
is communication
happens directly
between the peers, which
is much more efficient.
MALE SPEAKER: Once
connection is established,
do you never need any central--
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
Now of course, to do
this, there's no way,
at this point in time, to
just shout into the internet,
connect me to my friends.
You can't do that.
So you do need to negotiate the
connection, otherwise called
signaling.
And then we live in the
real world with NATs,
and firewalls, and
all this stuff,
so we also have something
called the ICE framework
that WebRTC uses.
It's been around
for a few years.
And it's a way of
connecting, even
when you have these
complex network scenarios.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Great.
So let's see.
What's new with WebRTC?
SAM DUTTON: Aw, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: I feel like I've
been hearing about WebRTC.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
Yeah.
I'll tell you what I
love at the moment.
I've seen amazing stuff with
using the other side of WebRTC,
which is the ability to
exchange arbitrary data.
So not just audio and
video, but arbitrary,
binary data, or just text.
And we've sent a couple
of things with that.
Something called
Sharefest, which
enables you to share
files between peers
in a completely
peer-to-peer way.
It's not going via some
intermediary server.
And that's yet
working very well.
Another similar application--
it's got a prototype
really called peerCDN.
And all you have to do is
incorporate, add the peerCDN
JavaScript to top
of your web page.
And then what it'll do is try to
get the content on the web page
from a peer that has the same
stuff, so the same images,
the same video, or whatever.
So in other words, it's a
peer-to-peer file distribution
set-up using WebRTC.
So CDN via WebRTC.
MALE SPEAKER: Nice.
SAM DUTTON: And
that's pretty cool.
MALE SPEAKER:
That's pretty cool.
Indeed.
So you mentioned mobile devices.
How real is WebRTC on
those mobile devices?
I mean, usually the
mobile, in terms
of supporting the standards and
the advanced HTML5 standards,
it's kind of trailing a bit.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So where
do we stand there?
SAM DUTTON: It's looking
good with WebRTC.
So all the APIs implemented
in Chrome and in Firefox
on mobile.
We've WebRTC bindings, in
fact, for Java and for iOS.
Still work being done on the
iOS stuff, but that's coming.
So we've got the ability
to do that stuff on mobile.
But also, I think one
of the main concerns
for us is battery life
and power consumption.
And what we're seeing
now is the integration
of hardware encoding.
So encoding and decoding
done in hardware,
much, much more efficient,
much less power consumption.
So that is a really huge
focus of the WebRTC team
at the moment, is making that
power consumption very, very
efficient and
working on hardware.
MALE SPEAKER: Good.
So WebRTC, just like
many other fields,
are filled with acronyms.
So you want to walk me through?
I think there are two that you
wanted to cover-- EME and MSE?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
Sure.
Yeah, so there are a couple
of related technologies
with using video.
There's something called EME
that people may have seen.
It stands for Encrypted
Media Extensions.
This is a standard being
developed by the W3C
to enable content
protection done
via the browser interacting
with a DRM system.
This means that a
distributor's broadcasters
can use web apps
without resorting
to plug-ins like
Flash and Silverlight.
The other one I
wanted to mention,
which is another one of
these alphabet city things
is MSE, which is Media
Source Extensions.
This is kind of
a complicated way
of saying that you can put
together a stream of video
in JavaScript from
chunks of videos.
Now what's
interesting about that
is that it enables you to do
things like adaptive streaming,
so raising and lowering
based on bandwidth,
and things like
time-shifting, and so on.
So yeah, two of the many
APIs adding richness
to video, the web.
MALE SPEAKER: So how is
Google using WebRTC today?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
So obviously, the move
is for Google Hangouts
to be using WebRTC.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
SAM DUTTON: And yeah,
that's, of course,
gives us better
quality and the ability
to do HD between, we hope,
more reliable connections.
That's, of course, a
huge push at the moment.
MALE SPEAKER: So we
talked about mobile.
How about accessibility?
I mean, people like Vint
Cerf advocate for the fact
that-- And we pride
ourselves in making
data available and accessible.
How is that part being--?
SAM DUTTON: This is
something dear to my heart.
There is something
called a track element
that you can use inside
a video element in HTML5.
And it's really simple.
It's just a text
file with timings
for what are called cues,
so subtitles or captions.
And you'd prompt that
in a video element,
link it to the text
file that has that data,
and then render it over the
video captions or subtitles.
Now that's cool,
but you can also
use that-- It's great for
accessibility, of course.
But you can also use that by
adding data in there, instead
of just plain old subtitles.
So then you've got this
incredible richness,
with the ability to add
timed metadata, essentially,
into a video.
So a million use cases for that.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
Yeah, that's very useful.
So you mentioned the video tag.
Anything new there?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
Some things I've seen recently.
I've worked with this
on Chrome, the ability
to use alpha transparency.
So what this means is you can
record a video, a green screen
video, and then in Chrome now--
I think it's still in Canary,
but it's coming
to Stable and it's
coming to mobile as well,
which is cool-- is the ability
to have a transparent
background.
So you can do things like
play one video over another.
Great for gaming.
Great for all
kinds of use cases.
People have been asking
for this for a long time.
That's one thing I love
which is brand new.
MALE SPEAKER: Coming to a
Chrome browser near you.
Awesome.
Anything fun you've seen
recently around WebRTC
that you found amazing
that people have built?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
Actually, I was just
thinking what's really new.
What I saw the
other day I loved.
Someone had built, for their
own use, a baby monitor.
Some techie, his
wife had a baby.
He was feeling
like he didn't want
to just use someone
else's system.
So he did this with WebRTC
using motion detection.
So it's really cool.
So it doesn't just sit
there and just show you
the video because you
could do that already.
So what it does is it shows
when there's some movement.
And then you can
do some tweaking
about when you
might be notified,
get it some kind of
alarm or something,
so you can check when your
baby's woken up and all
this stuff without having to
just permanently listen in.
But I love that sort of thing.
People have this DIY
developer spirit.
It's good.
MALE SPEAKER: That's
what it's all about,
enabling these developers
with great technologies.
And the sky's the limit.
There's so many things that
we haven't thought about it.
SAM DUTTON: No, it's great.
To me, this is an
incredibly rich API.
It's an amazing,
really, I think,
an amazing feat of engineering.
Just amazing.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
Well, Sam, thank you so much.
That's all the time
we have for you.
SAM DUTTON: Thanks
for having me.
MALE SPEAKER:
Guys, see you soon.
Cheers.